[Music]
welcome to sophie go visionaries me
sophie shepard not saying
deserted city streets all over the world
may already be a thing of the past and
now it's time to hit the lessons of this
pandemic
in organizing the space we live in in a
more reasonable
way well to discuss this i'm joined by a
world-renowned
expert on urban design young girl
yeah it's so great to have you with us
shortly before the pandemic i spoke to
two brilliant architects
rem kolhas and patrick schumacher and we
discussed how
urban environment and architecture
should be about
connecting people bringing them together
so that they could exchange ideas
experience knowledge is this concept
dead
now that the danger of a pandemic
dictates people to stay apart
rather than to be brought together
i think we shall we shall look at it
from a historic point of view
our settlements our cities have had many
problems over the years there has been
earthquakes and there's been fires
there's been
bombing there's been war there's been
flooding there has been epidemics
of virus epidemics of bacteria
and there has been a number of other
ailments and sicknesses
which we've had to cope with as human
beings
and the history will tell us that though
we are very panicking at this point and
we have all kinds of
restrictions and new ways of looking at
things
then when the doctors have found a
solution
to this pandemic
we will see in three years from now
things go back
to the way they used to be more or less
and people will say can you remember the
the corona
panic and the corona period oh that was
a special experience
but every time these things have
happened
mankind because mankind is much stronger
than a little bacteria or a little virus
mankind will return to the way
of living because
we have millions of years of social
development of biological development
which have brought us to where we are
and
made that we behave the way we do we can
adjust for a period
but when there is no limitations we just
return
to the natural way of being homo sapiens
so so
don't worry don't worry have hope
now i agree with you that we will
eventually go back to the way we were
because the pandemic is not here to stay
forever
but that period of time you said three
years
um that's still a long period of time
right for things to change around
for instance cholera and typhus in the
19th century when there were outbreaks
they led to the development of
water supplies sanitation systems in
europe
uh le corbusier took the tuberculosis
epidemic into consideration when
creating these landmark
objects what effect will the
kernel virus pandemic have on
architecture and urban planning because
we'll go back but not tomorrow it's
still going to take
some time at least until vaccine is
there and then we have to test it it's
two three years like you said
i think the the um the doctors will be
much faster and we will have some
medical
solutions to the problem much faster
than three years
but it will take a time for us to relax
and return to our
normal ways i think that it's very
different
this pandemic from the ones you are
mentioning
because in those cases that could be
done something with the sewers and the
running water and washing your fingers
and but this one is a virus
and actually i can see
some people say that we shall all move
out of the cities and live
separately on the country and i think
that's completely stupid
because because the main problem
we have as human beings are not the the
virus that is really the climate
challenge and we have to do something
about that's much more important
and to do something for the climate we
actually have
together together so we can have more
practical solution
to to energy and to pollution
and to we we will
um this one will will
i cannot see we we will have then
okay we'll have to make lifts in in
buildings
uh 16 square meters we'll have to make
stairs which are very wide
we'll have to do a lot of things which
is against
all the good things we have learned
to enjoy we know know that if we are
closer we are more intimate
if we are some distance we can be more
personal
then it's more social and the bigger
distance is more
official distance and of public distance
and we as human beings cannot live
without
being intimate and being close to other
people
only for a little while then we go back
to the way we have developed through
many years
for our communication but i have a
question
regarding people living outside the
cities
you've mentioned it's completely stupid
um
i can talk from my personal experience
that now that i have lived
in a big house outside of city for four
months
i would like to stay outside of city and
i know so many of my
friends who never before considered
living in a village
or in like a nature landscape outside
the city and now
at least 50 percent of them are
considering moving out of the city
it's almost like this pandemic has been
changing the landscape of the world
we are not talking about you and we are
not talking about you and your friends
where i see the media problems are the
great expansion of the population of the
world
and we we know that if
like in china they've started to move
into the cities
that has enabled china economically to
be able
to lift the living standard of the
people
and if we have this explosion of more
people in this world
we will have to move together where we
can produce more efficiently
where we can solve the transportation
problems more efficiently where we use
less energy where we can have
better better
training systems better warming systems
so we know that
to to to do something for the climate
it's much better that we live close
together and that we
actually have a situation where we can
get a better economy
to solve the problems of mankind so
spreading the whole world's population
out on the fields
will be a disaster for the climate
and for the resources so it may be a
solution for you
but not for mankind i hear you i never
i never looked at it from this way
because i thought i would be
helping villages and regions to develop
and stay alive
but i never looked at it this way from
the climate point you should also
think about just at one day maybe
many years from now you will be old and
you will need
some service from the community
they will have to come will send a
nurse three times a day and you will
have to bring you the meals and whatever
and you more spread out you live the
more expensive and the more
difficult it is to give you a necessary
service
when you are old or if you are sick or
if you are disabled
so this solution you mentioned is for
the young and fresh and for a period
but if we look at the whole life it is
we can
make a much better service if we live
together but we will have to make
um i think we've learned something from
this epidemic
maybe we've learned to wash our hands
that will be good
in the future also because we we always
had a too bad
higgins situation with hand washing that
could be better
we also learned that some of the jobs we
have
we can do on the computer
and that could that could be fine if
people say
two days a week work and hope at home
and three days a week only go to the
city
that will reduce transportation and
traffic with 40 percent
that's great but we should also remember
that we cannot say now everybody can
work from home
because not everybody can there are so
many jobs
which needs you to be there if you are a
nurse if you are a doctor if you
if you do the the
collect the garbage or if you are
in a hospital or if you are there are so
many
jobs in society which you cannot do
on a screen you have to be there you
have to
lift the bags and you have to do this
and that so
it is again it's very limited solution
to say
everybody work at home some of the
better off
and the most educated they can work at
home
but we can't buy it at home or all their
life
we will go crazy because we are so
dependent on working with other people
meet other people and an office is not
only a place where you meet other people
when the households are smaller and
smaller the offices
and the workplaces are also functioning
as sort of a family for you that's in
the office
you show pictures of your boyfriend or
your little child
that's in the office you cry with it
with your friends if you if you have a
bad luck in love it's in the office you
celebrate your birthday because
in many of our cities many households
are very small
in a city like copenhagen every other
unit is only inhabited by one person
and all these single person households
they need to come out and meet or they
go crazy
we cannot leave up looking at you i
would much rather sit in
a room with you than looking at you on
the screen
mr we're going to take a short break
right now when we come back
we'll continue talking about whether
this pandemic
will change the architectural landscape
of our cities stay with us
[Music]
and we're back with jan gal a
world-renowned expert on
urban design mr gel you're saying
that it is silly to change the
construction of the world because of the
pandemic it's silly to make staircases
now
four meters wide it's silly to make
really wide
elevators it's silly to make very wide
sidewalks right now that's what you're
saying because it's gonna come back to
normal
even though now a lot of people when
they're polled they're saying they don't
feel safe in public places unless
there's
a lot of space around them but there are
things that will still change
for instance hand washing i wash hands
every five minutes
do you think we'll have hand washing
stands in the streets like we have
for instance trash cans or elevators
with no buttons so you don't have to
push a button so you don't have to be
maybe maybe but i think we
we have to look at
in your house you don't make your house
so it's big enough for the daughter's
wedding
you make the house so it's comfortable
for your life
and if your daughter is going to be
married
either you squeeze together and have a
fantastic party anyway
or you go to another place for the
wedding you
think about a world where everything is
too wide
and too big and whatever think about
what you like yourself
you like very much the narrow streets
you might like the intimacy of the
village
you like the small dimensions you
don't like to be in a place where the
number of
high-rise towers and the wind is
sweeping between the towers
and everything is cold and white because
in our our senses
and our way of conceiving space is so
that
if you have big spaces you pick them up
as cold and impersonal if you have small
spaces
you pick it up as warm and cozy
and personal when you go on holiday
you go to places where there are small
dimensions
when you go to a camping square camping
place
there are small dimensions when you go
to a summer cottage place
to southern europe you seek out
cities with small and nice dimensions
you don't go to the places which
are blown up in space like dubai
or or things like that with a
silly modern architecture where
everything is too big
and too wide you don't feel comfortable
there
you feel you sometimes it's nice
some things are big but you are more
comfortable
with the human scale and we cannot leave
the human scale behind
to have a special corona scale which we
build too
will not be comfortable we'll regret it
and we cannot understand why we did it
when we have
we have vaccine for tuberculosis and
measles and a number of other things and
we don't think about it
anymore just to summarize what you're
saying
is that people right now should just
wait out for corona to disappear
for a vaccine to appear because
otherwise if we
put major changes in the way we live in
our cities
um in our villages then we're gonna
regret it
afterwards we're just summarizing what
you said so
we just have to wait out corona right
yes and be patient
and we have found that we can easily
live
in in the circ in the conditions we have
we can keep these distances and we can
wash our hands and we can
go on either side of the sidewalk it
works well
so it's been found that say in denmark
we
nothing has been done but people have
been asked to behave
differently for a while and i think that
shows that the same city can be used
also in a more healthy way in this
condition
we don't have to rebuild the city and
anyway we only build a little portion of
the city every year
so if we should rebuild the city it will
take hundred years
and we'll have many other things to
think about before these honda deals are
over
and as far as i'm concerned we have two
more important things to think about one
is this climate situation where we have
to do something radical rather fast
or we will have a very severe conditions
in many parts of the world the other
thing
is what the doctors call the sitting
syndrome
that is that people are driving too much
and sitting too much and are not using
their own body and their own
muscles enough and that's why we say in
city planning today
that we shall make places so that people
walk and bicycle as much as possible and
actually spend
much time outdoors um i want to
talk about transport in general because
we had this idea that cities around the
world are considering
their relationship with a car
focusing on public transport cycling
instead okay like a lot of people are
saying we don't need cars anymore
but now i'm sorry to bring you back to
coronavirus reality which i don't like
either
but it is what it is right now
chronowriter shows that
your car right now is the news in this
new circumstances
is the safest transit option
do you think the the trend of getting
rid of cars
is being reversed
i've heard that before but i don't think
that we'll see that
because the major problem again is that
we will need
mobility systems which are much more
sustainable and which will help us to
combat the climate crisis
i think that the major issue is our
cities have not room enough for all of
us
to go around with four rubber wheels
that was never possible
to have room for all everybody in a car
it would be a privileged
transportation mean so that's why i
think that
in the long run we'll see much more
very smart and very very attractive
public transportation and we'll see city
planning along the transportation
public transportation routes rather than
this
very privatized way of mobility
so so cars will become somewhat like
horses now right
for privileged people who can have those
horses on their ranches or on
hippodromes
motorboats okay
but not everyone lives in amsterdam
remember some people don't have rivers
in their cities
or canals yeah
but there will be need for cars
but i i do think that if we really look
at
the transportation problem there is a
lot
of private driving which is not
which could be done in other ways they
will need
ambulances and fire brigades and and
and garbage talks and delivery
uh in various ways but there's a lot of
especially commuting which can be done
in other ways
when we start to think uh more
smart and more sustainable at city
planning
i think that we are actually looking at
the end
of the era of the fossil fuel
fired motor car in denmark
after 2030 that's 10 years from now
you will not be able to buy any vehicle
which is running on gasoline or the
diesel
you will have to buy electric cars or
and more and more will be running on
electric and also
everything is done to have more people
bicycle
and have more people use public
transportation
and this is done for the climate and
this will not change
for because of a little virus for a
period
so let me ask you something everything
that we're discussing right now like
you're saying cities should be vibrant
they should be
dance people are fine they learn how to
live and social distance within
the reality that we have today uh
electric cars are these recipes
that we're talking about equally
applicable
to cities like copenhagen or delhi
or hanoi i mean it would be nice to have
all these things public
piazzas clean storefronts neighborhoods
but do developing countries have enough
resources to spare to spend on this
i'm quite i had written about it and
i have been in all these places and
i think that in developing countries
walking bicycling and good
cheap public transportation
will be the way which would be able to
solve in a sustainable and economically
feasible way the mobility problems
in the growing cities around the world i
think that we can never
imagine uh seven billion people
living in cities based on motor cars
not at all there's no room for that on
this globe
the globe is too small so we'll have to
we'll have to fight the the epitome
pandemics and the vira and bacteria
whatever we have of challenges
and then we'll have to solve the major
problems
of of urbanization and are bringing up
the wills
in the in the world so that more people
can
be lifted away from the poverty
onto a better lifestyle and we found
in china and other places that in the
cities you are able to have the
production
which can bring the economy to
raise the lifestyle and that is very
important
in the world that the number of poor
people is reduced
and the cities are actually one of the
ways
this is being solved
mr gill thank you so much for this
amazing
view of the world because not everyone
has such
precise and argumented view of the world
and why things should be the way that
should be it's been
a breath of fresh air talking to you
thank you so much
for your perspective and for your
thoughts i wish you
all the best of luck and i do hope that
we meet in person
soon to talk more about what we're
talking right now now you're talking
[Music]
thank you thank you so much thank you
goodbye
[Music]
you